[Musique]
mes chers compatriotes je veux que
l'once est confondre assistance avec
solidarité
si je suis élu président de la
république je vous montrais les
indemnités des chômeurs mais en
contrepartie je demanderai qu aucun
chômeur ne puisse refuser plus de deux
offres d'emploi correspondant à ses
capacités professionnelles je suis
président de la république je dirais à
tous les jeunes des quartiers difficiles
que je vais les aider à trouver une
formation et un emploi mais je leur dis
que nul ne peut demander d'être aidés
par la société s'il n'est pas capable de
se donner par lui-même le mal nécessaire
pour s'en sortir
[Musique]
je sais le malaise des enseignants qui
sont dévouées admirable de compétences
et d'engagement je connais le malaise de
l'école mon objectif pour l'école de la
république est simple je veux
l'excellence je veux qu qu'un jeune
puisse sortir sans savoir lire écrire
compter sans avoir une qualification qui
lui permettent dans la société de
connaissance qui est celle du xxième
siècle de se faire une place
je veux une école du respect je veux une
école de la transmission la transmission
de nos valeurs le travail le mérite
l'autorité le respect je veux pour
chacun d'entre vous la liberté de
choisir son école que cela soit l'école
publique où l'école privée je veux moins
d'élèves dans les classes difficiles
je veux une meilleure rémunération pour
les enseignants qui prennent la
responsabilité d'assumer l'enseignement
dans des milieux défavorisés où c'est
plus difficile où il faut s'engager
davantage
[Musique]
je veux dire aux français que je
garantirai votre santé je garantirai la
pérennité de vos retraites
je garantirai l'assurance maladie mais
joue également dire que je vais lutter
contre la fraude contre le gaspillage
public le personnel hospitalier mérite
mieux que d'avoir été totalement
désorganisé par les 35 heures qui ont
mis la pagaille à l'hôpital plus encore
que dans l'ensemble des autres services
publics
[Musique]
je veux engager une très grande ambition
au service de nos compatriotes les plus
âgés ceux qui sont dépendants
ce qui se retrouve frappé par ce drame
qu'est la maladie d'alzheimer je veux
que chacun puisse se dire qu'il pourra
terminer ses jours chez lui ou dans un
établissement digne et cheveux blancs
c'est beaucoup d'expérience beaucoup de
sagesse
c'est aussi beaucoup de courtoisie et
beaucoup de respect dans une société qui
en a besoin
et puis vous avez bien mérité de vous
reposer vous détend
si vous saviez comme j'aurais envie jo
[Musique]
je veux vous parler de vos retraites
nous allons vivre plus longtemps si nous
ne cotisons pas pu lui tant il n'y a
aucune chance que nous assurions
financement de nos retraites ce qui vous
propose de revenir sur les lois filles
sont ceux qui sont incapables de vous
garantir la pérennité au régime de
retraite et en même temps je sais qu'il
ya beaucoup de petites retraites
les artisans les agriculteurs les
commerçants trois millions d'entre vous
qui ont une retraite inférieure au
minimum vieillesse
j'augmenterais de 25 % vont rentrer
comment le financer
eh bien je ferai la réforme des régimes
spéciaux mais je poserai également la
question des pensions de réversion je
pense à toutes les veuves qui n'ont
jusqu'à présent que 54 % de la retraite
de leur mari défunt je veux porter un
minimum de 60%
cette pension de réversion et jeudi
également qu'à ceux qui veulent partir
plus tard parce qu'il se sent en pleine
forme et parce qu'ils veulent continuer
de travailler que je leur donnerai le
droit de continuer à travailler
[Musique]
la personne qui a un handicap par sa
spontanéité par sa gentillesse par son
désir de donner d'aller vers les autres
elle est importante pour notre société
le handicap
mes chers compatriotes ça peut frapper
tout le monde à n'importe quel moment
dans n'importe quelles conditions
le handicap c'est la maladie qui s'abat
où c'est l'accident qui brise une vie en
même temps qu'un corps et handicapées
doivent pas être regardés comme des gens
différents et handicapées seynod le
handicap porte des valeurs de courage de
dignité de soif de vivre qui sont utiles
pour la société française
beaucoup de français réclament la
solidarité moi je pense que s'il en est
une catégorie qui en a besoin c'est bien
celle des handicapés de leur famille je
répondrai à leur inspiration
je ne veux pas qu'on les laisse de côté
la façon dont on traite les handicapés
dans un pays c'est la façon dont on
respecte société et ce pays
[Musique]
mes chers compatriotes de métropole et
d'outre-mer la france est un tournant de
son histoire
votre choix sera d'une grande importance
je crois en la france en son talent en
songeant à sa capacité de surmonter les
épreuves durant ces quatre dernières
années nous avons dû affronter des
crises d'une violence inouïe
elle a souffert mais latin et la tenue
parce que nous avons agi l'immobilisme
nous aurait conduit au désastre pour les
cinq années qui viennent ce sont les
valeurs du travail de l'effort et du
mérite qui nous permettront d'être plus
fort et de reprendre la maîtrise de
notre liste
[Musique]
nous voulons la formation à chaque âge
de la vie pour lutter contre le chômage
nous devons agir pour que tout jeune qui
ne poursuit pas des études est un droit
à la formation professionnelle et à
l'alternance agir pour que tous chômeurs
qui ne trouvent pas de travail
suivent une formation et se voit offrir
un emploi correspondant à cette
formation
nous devons croire dans l'autorité parce
que l'autorité protège et que ce sont
les plus exposés qui en ont le plus
besoin
nous voulons une école où l'autorité du
maître et du savoir est reconnue parce
que nous ne pouvons éduquer nos enfants
sans un minimum d'autorité sans un
minimum d'exigences parce que le laxisme
ne rend pas service aux envies
[Musique]
nous devons agir pour que plus jamais un
enfant ne sortent de l'école primaire
sans maîtriser la lecture et l'écriture
nous voulons la responsabilité qui est
la condition et la liberté de chacun
parce qu'il n'y a pas de droits sans
devoirs parce que les droits les devoirs
c'est la morale de le république nous
devons croire la solidarité et refuse
l'assistanat
celui qui travaille doit toujours gagner
davantage que celui qui ne travaille pas
nous devons agir pour que la république
exige la connaissance du français et le
respect de nos valeurs
avant de pouvoir entrer sur le
territoire agir en divisant par deux le
nombre d'étrangers nous accueillerons
dans les cinq années qui viennent agir
pour obliger l'europe a changé en
exigeant qu'elle défende ses frontières
en luttant contre les délocalisations en
imposant la réciprocité dans les
échanges commerciaux
en refusant d'ouvrir nos marchés tant
que les autres n'auront pas fait et en
réservant nos marchés publics aux
entreprises qui produisent en europe
agir comme nous l'avons fait pour sauver
notre système de retraite
agir pour réduire nos dépenses et nos
déficits agir en adoptant une règle
d'équilibré obligatoire pour nos comptes
publics pour les cinq années qui
viennent
mes chers compatriotes c'est en restant
fidèles à nos valeurs
c'est en agissant que nous construirons
une france forte capable de protéger les
français et de leur rendre la maîtrise
de leur destin
[Musique]
la france est grande c'est cette chose
que je veux construire avec vous j'ai
besoin de vous
[Musique]